hello subscribers and Watchers now do
you ever just see or hear a story that
you just have to talk about the moment
you hear about it yeah I just did it is
official avatar is so good it's
apparently to die for now if you haven't
heard I guess a 42 year old man in
Taiwan had a stroke after watching
avatar and he died
now his doctor officially said that it
was most likely triggered by
over-excitement from watching the movie
are you serious that is the cap avatar
was the most excitement this guy's had
in his life I mean avatar was great nah
but think of all the other things a
human being might be able to do in his
life that might be a little more
exciting than avatar yeah I think we
officially found the new avatar tagline
avatar apparently it's better than sex
I'm just saying it is now a medical fact
and Who am I to argue with the phd's I'm
just saying the guy lived in Taiwan
getting sex and Taiwan is about as
complicated as yes I'll have the number
5 please thank you done yeah it's that
easy sorry here now I'm not saying we
overreact or anything but if we see a
surgeon general's warning on the avatar
blu-ray box yeah I will call [ __ ]
right there now another just as strange
and twice as dumb news although I really
don't know how I can follow up a story
about a guy having a stroke in Avatar
but I think I'm about to you guys
remember the movie push yeah does anyone
else Summit Entertainment has announced
a TV series based on the movie push push
being a good concept yet poorly executed
superhero movie and which a group of
ordinary people with superpowers team up
to take down an evil organization yeah
they're gonna take that premise and make
it a show ooh yeah someone beat you
there yeah they might want to rethink
the title of push and call it what it
really is heroes all right now let's try
this again and as much as it sounds like
a heroes ripoff as long as they don't
have one good season and follow it up
with three shitty seasons consisting of
a bad plot hollow characters and useless
side campaigns I guess they'd be a step
up from heroes in any case yeah I'm not
gonna watch it any more than you are how
is that show still on
it's like NBC's run by that really old
lady who refuses to put her sick dying
dog down in any case I thought these
stories were worth talking about because
they're ridiculous yes Jeremy let's skip
over the two earthquakes that rocked
Haiti you know real world issues to talk
about avatar causing a stroke and a
heroes ripoff series it has a guy with a
camera computer and Internet can
living in a world of studio douchebags
and Spidey reboots how can I not rant on
camera I mean seriously and as some of
you may have heard by now spider-man
four has officially been scrapped and
Sony is going forward with a spider-man
reboot officially telling us that two
out of three is still zero so what do
you guys think about that spider-man
reboot good bad necessary not necessary
I want to know what you know or at least
think and feel and if you like what you
see here click on the link in the
sidebar to see more videos and or
subscribe and if not I might try
subliminal messages that's come you got
the urge now don't you
[Music]